rehearsals begin today for Sunday
night's Grammy Awards on CBS amid a
whirlwind of controversy around the
group that puts them on suspended
Recording Academy CEO Deborah Dugan is
alleging major voting irregularities and
sexual harassment within the
organization now host Alicia Keys is
canceling all interviews and the Academy
has dropped today's ceremonial red
carpet rollout for the media Jamie
yuccas is in Los Angeles how else is
this affecting the show Jamie well
Anthony Billy Eilish Liz oh and Ariana
Grande are still set to perform but
Duggan's allegations are also taking
center stage among the most serious is
that the Grammys are rigged with secret
committees selecting the final list of
nominees some of whom might not have
been the top choices of voting Academy
members as in years past The Recording
Academy is still promoting Sunday
night's Grammy Awards as music's biggest
night but Deborah Duggan's accusations
are putting a harsh spotlight on the
integrity of the nominations variety
senior music editor gem aswad the
industry's general reaction to this
complaint has been horror Dugan was put
on administrative leave last week after
she was accused of misconduct she then
leveled her own accusations against the
Academy in a complaint filed Tuesday
saying in part that nomination review
committees are shrouded in secrecy and
ultimately control in large part who is
nominated she claims one artist who came
in 18th an initial voting for song of
the year not only sat on the committee
deciding those nominees but is
represented by a member of the Academy
Board
she says that artists wound up as one of
the final nominees I got an earful about
how angry the creative community is
about it there has not been a smoking
gun quite like this one
Dugan's complaint also highlighted
examples of the Academy's alleged lack
of diversity saying minority groups are
historically underrepresented as both
nominees and winners she pointed to
Adele's win over Beyonce for Best Album
in 2017 which even appeared to shock the
artists
self the lemonade album was just so
monumental on Wednesday for women
serving on the Board of Trustees
released a statement defending the
Academy and its diversity and inclusion
task force launched in 2018
they say the task force has created a
clear path to follow and open the door
to building even more bridges to the
music community at large behind the
scenes at the Recording Academy it's
probably pretty chaotic and pretty
alarmed right now clearly they did not
anticipate what has happened now in that
complaint filed on Tuesday Dugan also
claimed that her predecessor former CEO
Neil portnow was accused of rape and
that was the real reason his contract
was not renewed portnow released a
statement yesterday calling those
allegations ludicrous and untrue going
on to say that he was completely
exonerated by an in-depth independent
investigation and the president of the
Recording Academy now says two
independent investigations have been
launched he says he will work to make
quote needed repairs and changes based
on those findings Anthony a lot of
turmoil Jamie thank you and in our next
hour Deborah Dugan will be here in
studio 57 to talk about this controversy